you'd mentioned just a bit ago that if
you do something innovative
and you stay with it people notice
what i've seen is that people come up
with wonderful ideas and they don't
stick with it they expect it to be
you know a year in and if it's not
making them a million dollars or six
figures and they abandon it or they get
tired of it so do you have any tips for
people to kind of keep that fire going
with a project even though and you may
be the only one beating that drum
i'd almost answer that question in the
opposite
of what you've asked which is i i use my
my fire for a project
my projects are not two-year projects
okay they might take two years to bring
to fruition but they don't take up
large amounts of my time for two years
so my projects compared to many projects
are relatively short-term you know as
compared to their feature film
so
i that kind of fire inside if i lose
that fire about a project
i almost take it as a sign if i'd lost
fire about this project why should
anybody else
care about it you know and that's one of
the signs and because what i tend to do
is i don't take one project and push it
forward i'm in quite a fortunate
position in fact because i'm an academic
i am salaried
all right so i get money every month no
matter what and they let me spend at
least 50 of my time
doing what i want to do as long as it's
good for the university so doing the
composing or the filmmaking
and
so what i do because of that i can take
a relatively risky approach i throw lots
of projects at the wall i come up with
loads of project ideas i start off far
too many projects i send far too many
emails to loads of people
and what happens is some projects just
die and they die quite naturally in this
in and it tends to be i just lose
interest in them and i do use that as a
barometer almost um
there will come a time even in shorter
term projects however
and it but for me it's not about losing
enthusiasm what it's about is is just
pain it's just the stress you've got a
fixed date when this has to be shown or
performed um and something's gone wrong
i mean and and the the the emotions are
so
intense
that they override the rational mind so
it almost sometimes it can seem like a
problem can't be solved the point i've
just the reason i'm in la is because i
was invited to do a performance for
stanford at the california academy of
sciences
in san francisco so i drove down here
for a holiday afterwards anyway
that performance i was there
in the academy in front of the world's
top physicists
and
set up the equipment for my subatomic
particles and my violinist
and the equipment for the subatomic
particles was not working this was
within an hour having traveled halfway
across the world to do this performance
within an hour of the performance the
equipment wasn't working now it wasn't
that it wasn't working what it was is
there was a problem that needed to be
fixed but i was so emotionally
overwrought and so cons for the pressure
was so much
that it felt
that what my mind was saying is i could
fail
i could fail i'm gonna fail what if i
fail whereas what i what you have to do
is overcome that and in spite of that
it's got to be
i've got to solve this i've got to solve
this i can and then eventually i was
like
i can solve this
and i remember another situation with
that same performance the premiere back
in england at plymouth university
because that was actually uh it was uh
commissioned by peninsula arts at
plymouth university and we had the
premier there
because i'm a member of the
interdisciplinary center for computer
music research which is where we
developed it now i am
i remember a few days before that
performance somebody said to me
um this may not be able to
i don't want to go into details but
basically something happened two days
before which may have meant the
performance couldn't happen and i
remember sitting at my desk and i
remember thinking
this pain is too much i can't i can't
cope with this stress it'd have been in
multiple papers already i'd produced a
video which had gone around the web
and i remember sitting at my desk and
just my head sinking to my hands and
just thinking i can't cope with this but
then a short time after i thought i have
to cope with this and i think that
does develop muscles inside of you but
it also makes me i remember i tweeted
after the san francisco performance
because it was a great success the
performance at san francisco
a couple of days ago was a great success
so and i remember tweeting kind of
saying you know why why do i do this to
myself
am i a masochist why would i do this but
of course the reason i do it
that performance that thing i did
no one else has done that
maybe there's very few people around who
would want to do it it's an expression
of me you know and i got the opportunity
to be paid to do that to put it on
and i've done that now you know no one
can take that away from me i was at that
venue in front of those people in that
city
doing what for some people might think
was impossible and i did it and and
that's it that's a bit of my life now
done and there's a few things and a lot
of those
when i look back have been arts things
over the last few years you know i
achieved that i did that i did that and
that's
that's i've got that for the rest of my
life now
you